en 2014
j'ai eu la chance
olympiques de sotchi jalel à bord pour
pas ni un athlète un athlète qui
performait aux olympiques
j'étais très chanceux de me retrouver
sur le plus beau terrain de jeu au monde
j'étais curieux de savoir également
parce que je te lis mené une petite
enquête la boj allait faire une
exploration dans le but d'écrire un
livre un livre qui avait pour thème du
rêve à la réalité
donc je suis là à sotchi plus beau
terrain de jeu au monde pour moi
curieux de savoir comment ces hommes et
ces femmes des géants dans leur
discipline avait fait pour faire de leur
rêve une réalité réalité olympique et là
je vais vous faire un petit aveu parce
que l'information que j'allais chercher
là bas ma curiosité bien il y avait une
raison et cette raison la soute est
l'échec
quelques années auparavant j'avais eu
une forme d'échec
j'avais eu un projet sur lequel je
travaille je vais travailler un grand
rêve et je n'avais pas vu la totalité le
plein potentiel de ce projet là donc je
me retrouve à sotchi à faire des
entrevues avec des athlètes avec les
coaches avec les entraîneurs puis
j'étais curieux aussi je me posais des
questions aux membres de la famille
j'étais vraiment à vis de d'abord le
plus d'informations possibles mais bien
souvent ce que je leur demandais en
premier c'était qu'est ce qu'un athlète
a besoin pour se rendre ici aux
olympiques c'est quoi les meilleurs
atouts ayant une coach canadienne qui
m'a répondu c'était la première réponse
que j'ai eu un athlète a besoin de
savoir composer avec les chèques ne
comprendre l'échec et de s'en servir
comme levier pour devenir meilleur pour
aller plus loin
lorsque vous dire que ça faisait un
petit résonance avec moi puis mon passé
donc celui-là
très curieux a fouillé à apprendre plein
d'informations à me laisser inspirer par
tout ce que je pouvais aller récolter
par les choses que je voyais les
conférences de presse les discussions
que je pouvais avoir
puis à un moment je me suis retrouvé au
premier niveau là pour
une remise de cérémonie deux médailles
et là se voyait les athlètes
littéralement sauté sur le podium pour
aller chercher leur médaille je voyais
le sourire je voyais la fierté dans le
visage tutelle en avant puis je me
disais wow c'est dans ce genre de fierté
là moi que j'ai envie de vivre ma vie de
retour à montréal
j'ai commencé à travailler sur mon livre
puis naturellement dont j'avais quand
même de très belles histoires à pouvoir
raconter mais je resterai avec un espèce
de feeling de vie d'intérieur
je me suis dit à un moment donné c'est
bien beau le rêve olympique c'est bien
beau les histoires des autres mais est
ce que c'est vraiment ça que j'ai envie
de faire dans la vie de raconter
l'histoire des autres
un matin je me souviens je me suis levé
le regarde dans le miroir puis je me
suis posé une petite question qui peut
paraître assez simple je me suis
demandée pitois normand piché c'est quoi
ton rêve
ironiquement j'ai pas été capables de
répondre alors j'ai quand même fait un
petit bout des trop spéciaux et j'ai
fini par le trouver naturellement
mais avant d'aller plus loin et j'ai
envie de vous poser la question lever la
main dans la salle les gens qui
connaissent leurs rêves qui ont un rêve
précis à accomplir qui seraient prêtes à
embarquer dedans quand même intéressant
il ya quand même pas mal de monde qui
n'ont pas levé la main donc quelques
temps plus tard le rêve aurait émergé le
rêve de relier cinq continents à la nage
ça consistait en quoi en fait
cinq traversées autour du monde la
première consistait à relier la russie à
l'alaska dans le détroit de béring
traversée donc de l'asie à l'amérique
deuxième étape le pacifique un petit
tronçon dans le pacifique pour relier la
papouasie nouvelle guinée à l'indonésie
ensuite on se dirigeait vers l'europe la
turquie et la grèce
je relis et la turquie à la grèce pour
faire de l'asie à l'europe
4e traversée de l'espagne au maroc dans
le détroit de gibraltar et finalement de
relier l'egypte à la jordanie dans la
mer
ouf ça s'est passé le 24 août dernier on
a quitté montréal moi et l'équipe on
était cinq personnes a voyagé et le 17
novembre
on est revenu à montréal j'avais gagné
mon pari les cinq traversées avait été
réalisé et on revenait avec un rêve qui
était devenu réalité
ça peut sembler un petit peu simple
comme ça mais j'ai envie de vous ramener
quelques jours avant de revenir à
montréal le 15 novembre
on est en jordanie je suis sur la
terrasse de ma chambre d'hôtel en avant
de moi il ya la mer rouge qui est
éclairé par la lune c'est très beau en
fait c'est la première fois qu'on se
retrouve chacun des membres de l'équipe
à avoir chacun notre chambre parce que
pendant les trois mois qu'on est en
expédition presque trois mois on a
toujours vécu ensemble dans des petites
pièces dans des petits appartements ce
jour sur cet ensemble 24 heures par jour
ensemble dans la proximité
et là je me retrouve seul d'avoir une
espèce de d'immensité c'est magnifique
le ciel est plein des toiles puis en
avant un peu en billets je peux voir
l'egypte l'egypte on l'avait quitté le
matin très tôt il faisait noir encore
pour rejoindre la jordanie un peu à ma
droite bassil israël qui est la ville
dilate et à gauche
l'arabie saoudite qui est issu des
frontières de l'arabie sont là à peu
près une dizaine de kilomètres une
espèce de de gros nuages de lumière au
dessus de l'arabie puis nous ici en
egypte en egypte mais plutôt en jordanie
c'est assez sombre mais je peux quand
même voir l'ensemble du désert voir le
profil des montagnes et ses magnifiques
le chili que je regarde le sabot de
calais puis j'ai un petit peu de
difficulté à y croire je viens de relier
cinq continents à la nage
je viens de faire le pont entre dix pays
au delà des frontières
parce que des frontières il y en avait
beaucoup
il y avait les frontières géopolitiques
naturellement puis toutes les
autorisations que ça la nécessité aux
quatre coins du monde pour pouvoir faire
les traversées en fait les autorisations
ça a été le nerf de guerre de notre
expédition il y avait les frontières ben
culturelles religieuses linguistiques
les frontières une
voyager à 5 personnes à un moment c'est
pas toujours facile puis au delà de tout
ça bail avec mes propres frontières à
moi les miennes mes limites physiques
mentales
puis mes peurs parce que quand j'ai
trouvé mon rêve
j'ai quand même pas juste trouver un
rêve que j'ai également trouvé des peurs
il y en avait plusieurs
initialement je le disais que
premièrement c'était beaucoup trop gros
comme projet que ça n'avait pas de sens
que c'était totalement irréaliste que
c'était pour me coûtait beaucoup trop
cher puis j'avais peur de tout les
sacrifices qu'ils étaient pour que je
vais devoir faire en m'engageant dans ce
projet là les sacrifices ça a été moins
compliqué parce que j'avais décidé de
voir ça un peu comme des choix je me
disais ça implique des transformations
dans ma vie mais voyons ça comme des
choix parce que ça pourrait aussi
m'amener à vivre la plus belle
expérience de ma vie donc je suis sur ma
terrasse
j'observe tous âges est en train de
digérer tout ce qui vient de se passer
je repense à la traversée de la journée
huit heures de nage sans arrêt pour
relier les deux pays
quand il a le temps de boire puis de
manger je devais me retourner sur le dos
pour cliquer parce que cette journée là
c'était le 15 novembre c'était le jour
de la traversée et on ne pouvait pas
composer avec la météo
pourquoi parce que dans parmi les
autorisations on avait eu besoin des
autorisations du ministère de la défense
de l'egypte est très très compliqué et
la seule journée qu'on pouvait le faire
celle que nous avons donc on s'était
quand même embarqué dans l'aventuré dans
une mer qui était chaotique huit heures
de nage à langer donc sans arrêt à côté
de moi ben il y avait quelqu'un en kayak
qui étaient là pour s'assurer de bien me
diriger la direction pour s'assurer de
ma sécurité
parce que moi naturellement j'ai des
yeux dans l'eau puis ça prenait
quelqu'un pour voir alentours les
prédateurs marins
parce que ça faisait partie des dangers
dans la mer rouge particulièrement il ya
des rockets
j'en ai vu d'ailleurs plusieurs j'en ai
vu une une trentaine étaient petits
comme ça gros comme ça des bébés enfin
il y avait enfin un pack et d'objectifs
de défis à relever quand on pense au rpt
détroit de béring cdo glacial mais c'est
aussi les orques qui sont là c'est aussi
des morses des phoques dans le pacifique
c'est un petit peu plus calme le tronçon
que j'ai fait mais il y avait des
méduses des méduses qui était assez
redoutable qui pouvait même être
mortelle
heureusement ça ne m'est pas arrivé mais
j'ai été piqué tout le long de la
traversée sentiment de brûlures de choc
électrique de lames de rasoir qui
passent sur les parties de la peau qui
sont exposés à l'eau le gibraltar des
défis quand même assez un portable parce
qu'il gibraltar c'est le détroit où il
ya le plus de circulation maritime au
monde
deux cargos donc se faufiler à travers
quelque chose comme 300 à 500 cargo ce
qui amène aussi son lot de pollution la
mer rouge mais je vous ai parlé des
petits requins je vous ai parlé d
énormes vagues
alors je vous parlais du gars qui
m'accompagne qu'ils voient à cette
espèce de sécurité lui les yeux hors de
l'eau mois ils sont dans l'eau dans un
monde qui est assez fascinant un monde
qui mystique
l'os est mon élément préféré j'adore et
moi je nage le visage dans l'eau puis à
peu près 50 fois par minute mais je
tourne la tête comme ça pour prendre une
respiration
j'ai à peine la bouche qui sort de l'eau
pour respirer dans le creux de la vague
puis je retourne à l'eau et je nage un
peu un petit peu plus loin nous il ya un
bateau qui est là sur le bateau il ya
les autres membres de l'équipage qui
sont là avec avec un groupe d'égyptiens
des dignitaires des militaires des
journalistes et qui nous suivent cette
espèce de gros bateaux là quand je peux
le voir je le vois aller comme ça il se
promène son espèce de gros bateaux là
puis je me dis oh my god sa brosse la
supplie à genoux je me dis moi
je porte dessus je suis dedans jeune âge
hélas un moment ben je me tourne ça fait
des heures là qu'on a quelques heures
puis je regarde sylvain rapidement
naturellement et puis j'ai dit on est
rendus ou puis j'entends moitié
je continue à manger j'ai dit on et où
il dit on n'est pas rendus à la moitié
au bruit intense quand je vous dis que
c'était le chaos c'était vraiment le
chaos pour vous donner une idée
l'énergie que je devais déployés à ce
moment là c'était deux à trois fois ce
que je donnais dans des traversées où
c'était plus calme
quand je disais que si je m'arrêtais un
petit peu on reculait alors je leur
jeune âge puis je me dis oh ben je suis
rendu à la 5e traverse et les autres ont
été réussis ont tout lire les les
traverser toutes les destinations je
vais emmener un long énorme défi chaque
traversée est un petit miracle parce
qu'on ait failli ne pas les faire mais
là on est rendu à la dernière sur le
bord de réaliser mon rêve et je commence
à avoir des doutes
ça fait deux ans que je me prépare pour
faire cette expédition là une
préparation qui a quand même été assez
importante
j'ai dû nager un petit peu plus de 2500
kilomètres juste pour me préparer pour
vous donner une idée au niveau des
petits coups de brosse sénat représente
à peu près deux millions je vous parle
des disques ou de broc parce que je vais
revenir à la traversée en fait avec
toutes mes peurs que j'avais au début
c'est ce que je m'étais dit le petit
coup de bras je m'étais dit au lieu de
penser à toutes les limitations au lieu
de penser à tout ce qui peut te faire
pas les faits dont le 6 points le
premier support embarque dans le chemin
ton rêve puis voisine un coup de broc à
la fois et hubert robert ou est-ce que
ça me tenait le café viennois des heures
et des heures que je nage que je donne
des coups de bras que je redoute
d'arriver là-bas et à un moment je me
mets à penser à toutes sortes de choses
je pense à ma fille entre autres que je
vais revoir dans deux jours je pense à
ma mère d'obama mon père j'avais quand
même vu des belles bases parce que ma
mère
l'enseigné d'avoir la foi avait toujours
dit si tu crois profondément dans tes
rêves que tu te mets en action mais tout
est possible
puis mon père lui ben ce qu'il me disait
c'est mettre l'amour dans ton coeur je
me souviens bien de l'amour dans son cas
croix dans tes rêves profondément passer
à l'action mais de l'amour dans ton
coeur puis lors quand même malgré les
difficultés
j'étais dans l'eau dans un élément que
j'aime qui me passionne j'y donnais de
mon coeur puis je continuer d'avancer
un petit coup de brosse à la fois je me
suis remis à avoir plein d'image
justement mon enfance le petit normand
hyperactif très créatif mais inarrêtable
qui avait eu des patins de hockey dans
les pieds avant même peut-être de marché
parce que l'eau qu'ils savent c'était
l'histoire de mon père c'est son rêve y
avait joué dans ligue européenne qui
rêvait de la ligue nationale mais ça
n'avait pas fonctionné
puis il m'avait transposer un peu son
rêve je me revoyais atik eu à peu près
au comme ça lui dire un peu en train de
chez keek j'arrêtais de jouer au hockey
parce que là ok c'était pas mon dada
c'était le sien moi j'avais bu de danger
je me suis revu à l'adolescence les
premiers projets les premiers voyages en
train de voyager puis à chaque fois que
je revoyais des images comme ça ça me
donnait de l'énergie pour continuer jrv
une vingtaine quand j'ai commencé quand
j'étais à l'école mais mes cours à
l'école quand j'ai rencontré la femme de
ma vie
quand j'ai commencé à travailler dans le
showbiz en tant que gérant d'artistes et
ce moment là bah écoutez c'était la vie
bien distincts extraordinaire c'était
beau et puis en plus en amour on était
one puis on avait des rêves puis on
voulait les réaliser j'ai revu la
trentaine aussi je nageais puis je
repassais à des moments plus difficiles
les belles réalisations mais des échecs
aussi qui avait été la cible du genre de
claque en plein visage que sur soi
pick-up stats amp au taureau le suicide
d'une personne très proche à la
séparation amoureuse familial puis
toutes ces choses là je pensais bien je
continue à manger puis je me disais
quand même tout sépare alors que je
pouvais faire avec l'eau vive
c'était faux mais première
merci quand je suis arrivé de l'autre
côté après huit heures de nage
ça m'avait semblé comme un coup de doigt
le temps avait passé puis malgré les
douleurs que j'avais développé à cause
des courants cause des vagues à me faire
brosser
j'avais plus de douleur j'avais le goût
de retourner de l'autre côté de
retourner à la nage en egypte
l'adrénaline
enfin qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce qui
est porte quelqu'un pourquoi s'embarquer
dans un projet comme celui là j'ai le
goût de vous dire pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas s'embarquer dans des trucs comme
celui là moi en fait c'était la réunion
l'ensemble de toutes les choses que
j'aime faire la nage voyager découvrir
le monde
c'était l'idée de relever des filles des
défis de sentir que je donnais du sens à
ma vie puis à la vie en général c'était
de passer à travers la montagne
d'émotion et la montagne russe
d'émotions au quotidien et dans fait de
me sentir en vie est-ce que ça a été
facile ce projet là absolument pas à
tous les jours dès le début jusqu'à la
fin
il ya eu des obstacles il ya eu des
défis à relever et des situations
complexes mais ma petite philosophie que
j'avais là dessus c'était tout
simplement de me dire que si on a un
problème c'est parce qu'une solution
mais s'il n'y a pas de solution c'est
parce qu'il y en a pas de problème puis
à force de trouver des solutions
c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi à faire
l'expédition est-ce que je recommencerai
totalement je repartirai tout de suite
en quittant ici pour revivre une
expérience comme seul parce que dès le
début dès le départ ont quitté pour
l'expédition puisque déjà en train de
penser à une nouvelle expédition
parce que dans l'action baisse à la mène
des résultats puis dans leurs rêves
salle amène de nouveaux rêves
effectivement ben j'ai déjà la tête
pleine d'idées prête à repartir sur une
nouvelle expédition puis de me lancer à
l'aventuré à nouveau avant de terminer
j'ai envie
vous poser une petite question bien
simple en apparence et ceux qui n'ont
pas levé la main et vous c'est quoi
votre rêve et la deuxième c'est quoi le
premier sport que vous pouvez faire pour
embarquer dans le choix de votre rêve
merci
[Applaudissements]